um yeah man uh what a time though man I  do feel like you know we got to give you  your flowers for being somebody who  really kind of revolutionized the genre  and kind of created your own genre  within r b  um  and I feel like nowadays we really hear  your influence on music in general  um do you feel like uh maybe you don't  get enough flowers in terms of just kind  of  bring in a new  genre into I guess a sub-genre of music  into r b  um  I mean I've I've seen a lot of people  say trap soul and but that but don't  mention my name you know what I'm saying  or I see people  talk about Kentucky and don't mention my  name which is crazy it's nuts well  that's crazy as well right yeah yeah  don't ever do it again don't let it  happen again right yeah so uh nah but  it's all good though it's all up